[Musique]
comment tu te sens aujourd'hui
c'est horrible c'est horrible est
horrible c'est horrible pour moi c'est
surtout horrible pour ma femme qui se
fait insulter dans des proportions qui
dépassent tout ce qu'on peut me
reprocher dans probablement à juste
titre dans ce nom ce documentaire et
danser à côté mais voilà il ya une
déferlante de haine de menaces de mort
de 2 à base de rente et organes
j'espère que tu vas aller sur le
trottoir enfin bon je peux pas
comprendre les insultes je peux pas
comprendre les menaces de mort mais je
peux comprendre qu'on me critique de
façon même assez violente
dans cette séquence jeudi une seule
connerie c'est que leurs frais voilà
pourquoi parce que lorsque marie ma
scène cette histoire de jus je suis
estomaqué tu te rappelles plus un
musulman rappelle plus mais maintenant
en syrie le jeu c'est pourquoi je ne me
rappelle plus il se trouve que le 28
août 2016 ça a été ma dernière émission
avant que je tombe malade et que je
disparaisse des écrans pendant sept
manches donc je pense que ce soir là je
n'étais pas dans mon état normal tu fais
de la télé il ya dix ans je sais pas
combien de personnes t'embrasser sur la
bouche il ya dix ans les retenir
moi d'ailleurs j'ai embrassé 2010
gribout j'ai embrassé je prends bien et
mais évidemment quand je joue à la fen
avec francesca je ferai plus à
aujourd'hui le monde a changé ses mythes
où on peut plus rien faire on peut plus
rien dire mais ce que je me ce que jenny
dans le dans le dock et que je maintiens
c'est que pour moi une fille un homme
c'est pareil et si on ne peut pas
chambrer une fille parce que c'est une
fille pour moi c'est insupportable sur
le moment je n'ai pas du tout vécu comme
une agression sexuelle parce que c'est
le terme que j'entends et qui est
employé sur les réseaux sociaux moi je
n'ai pas du tout vécu comme ça mais j'ai
vécu comme une humiliation parce
qu'après il faut être honnête il faut
aussi dire les choses parfois dans ce
métier là en tant que journaliste
sportive on se retrouve à être humilié
parce que yahia voilà il ya des mots qui
sont blessants il ya des comportements
et le fait qu'on soit une femme
voilà autorise certains a manqué de
respect et ce geste là quand je le
revois voilà c'est pas agréable c'est
pas agréable
maintenant bleus
de dire que je les ai vécus comme une
agression sexuelle ce serait faux pour
tout ce qui s'est passé l'âge et des
profonds regrets vraiment et sincèrement
que ce soit pour francesca que germe
depuis très longtemps
isabelle marie m'enfin bon mari j'ai
quand même accepté d'y aller faire son
truc
si ça n'a pas été diffusée c'est pas de
mon ressort